Oh roman choc cinémas de la ville Giorgio
Jeffrey Jessie Tywin Lannister la
femme rouge Je ne peux pas dormir jusqu'à ce que je dise les
noms les noms de chaque personne à
Westeros seulement ceux que je vais tuer
Robb Stark est mort
Je reste éveillé toute la nuit en pensant à  comment
ils sont morts
il a été trahi par ses propres hommes ou nous pouvons
lui rendre maintenant c'est la justice
si vous voulez la justice
vous êtes au mauvais endroit je
ne serai pas la page du
livre d'histoire de quelqu'un d'autre que faisons-nous à ceux
qui ont  blesse ceux que nous aimons le jour
viendra où ta joie se transformera en
cendres dans ta bouche
et tu sauras que la dette est payée les
Lannister sont les seuls à payer
leurs dettes je ferai ce que font les reines
[Musique]
je gouvernerai
[  Musique]
[Musique]